the reason why this all bothers me is
because
human subjectivity is variable and what
happens with these kinds of discourses
is a very
um static very weak very vulnerable
subjectivity is posited as progressive
but we need a powerful subjectivity
we need a changing subjectivity
if we are to fundamentally change the
world if we are to
take the reigns of history mark says but
we will make history in the full light
of reason
and where and capitalism is bringing us
you know the veil is lifted and we're
getting closer and closer to the truth
of
the human hands on history we have to
realize that
it is us that have done everything we
have created religions we have created
these institutions
we can recreate them we can make them
different and all of these discourses
invite us to think no no no
we're all just a bit messed up aren't we
it's so hard to control our minds and
we're just your better self because
you're weak and isn't it so progressive
to accept that
[Music]
hello plastic pills listeners we have a
very special episode here today
where we're talking with professor
ashley frowley but today we're here to
talk about her work
on the semiotics of happiness uh that's
quite a mouthful but believe me by the
end of this
we will all at least be a little bit
more uh
experts on what it means to be happy how
we can be happy
and we'll discover whether or not it's
society that's making us unhappy
uh whether or not it's ourselves that
are making us unhappy or if the concept
itself doesn't really make sense
exactly uh so thanks a lot uh dr foley
for coming here we really appreciate it
well thanks for having me so your book
the semiotics of happiness uh make
creative wave
and that it was interrogating a very
popular subject matter right now
um what does it mean to be happy how do
we conceptualize happiness
and of course how does society
conceptualize happiness uh in the kind
of
grammars and ideologies uh that are put
forth in the 21st century
uh and we were just wondering if you
could tell us a little bit before we get
into the nitty gritty
theoretical details of the book about
why you chose to focus on this topic
what was the allure
of happiness as it were um well i
started that
the research became that book in 2008
so quite a long time ago um but what
initially drew me to the subject matter
was um well not before i did my phd
i'm still living in canada um and my
final year of my undergraduate degree
um i took a class
called the advanced sociology of mental
health
and it was literally the very first time
saying we read foucault and all that
kind of stuff but also the
kind of critical literature looking at
the concept of mental health and
concept of well-being and um labeling
theory and all of that sort of thing
it was literally the first time in my
life that i learned that
actually these concepts are contested
um these things have a history a ver a
contested history
that there are many different ways of
being and relating to the world
all around the world and historically
and we didn't always relate to the world
in this way that this sense that
you know something bad happens to you
you're damaged
um when you have some kind of
personality trait that you don't like
you think back to what your parents did
and blame them
the idea that this has only been around
for like 100 years
shocked me because i thought well this
is actually just like the scientifically
validated way that human beings
are and actually on on a personal level
it
liberated me because up until that point
i had very much
been like enmeshed in this what
sociologist now called
therapy culture um this this
way of relating to the world these
meanings that emerge from the side
disciplines that have come into the
world
um and um sort of suffused
all of our the way that we talk about
ourselves when we talk about our
relationships the way we relate to
institutions even the way that we
construct our social movements i've been
like sort of inundated with the language
of psychology and the
the belief systems of psychology and the
understandings of social problems that
come from psychology
it's a very new kind of thing um and i
had been part of that world and i just
thought well that's the way things are
that's
that's just reality that's how you're
supposed to construct a movement
um that's how you're supposed to
construct a grievance that kind of thing
and
in terms of like happiness discourses i
remember that i used to read like
self-help books and that kind of thing
because i you know i
probably you seem to be about my age
maybe a little bit younger
um but you um you know
growing up doesn't come with a rule book
you know tradition is gone
and all of these old categories have
lost their meaning so
for me you know being 19 20 years old it
was like well what am i supposed to be
you know i say to my dad like well what
should i do and he'd be like ashley you
just be happy you know whatever makes
you happy i'm like no no no
you tell me what am i supposed to be
what am i supposed to do
what does it mean to be a woman what
does it mean to be a man i have no flip
an idea
and we we've destroyed all these
categories all these old traditions
not saying that that's a bad thing i'm
just saying that everything that used to
give a guide for life is gone
so how do you find these things well
well how do you find rules how do you
know how to live well we find it in
self-help books we find it in like 10
steps to a better you
and so that's what i was doing and i was
miserable because i was
constantly focused on myself i was
obsessed with my feelings and i was
always thinking like
i remember i put affirmations on my wall
like um
don't save up your happiness for the
future be happy now and i was like oh
like why can't i just be happy you know
and i couldn't because i was so focused
on myself and my own psychology because
that was the be all in the end all of
everything
i thought that was the whole point um
and so to learn that this had a history
and this is not how people used to
relate to the world you know reading
christopher lash you know we've lost our
sense of belonging to historical time
this idea that people didn't used to
live as though they had one last
life to live they lived as though they
were living their parents lives and
their children's lives
blew my mind absolutely blew my mind and
also i was a bit angry because i was
thinking
you know i had been lied to more or less
about the
about human nature it was always the
answer to everything anytime i mean well
why is that things like why are things
like this well because of human nature
or if you wanted to get real complex
because
on the savannah grasslands you know they
tell this just so story that explained
everything
um and so i i went into i went to go do
a phd
um to study happiness because as i was
taking this class in my final year of
university
um i was interested in studying the
labeling of depression
um because i had had this sort of you
know personal experience of being like a
16 year old going to my
high school counselor because my
grandmother died and i was very upset
about this
and other things that were happening in
my life at the time as you are when
you're a teenager
and uh she was like wasn't she wasn't
listening to me she was taking off a
list of symptoms
and she was like it's not you it's
depression you have a chemical imbalance
in your brain
and at first i was like oh my god that
is so i felt better you know
um it's not me it's my brain as though
there's like some separation there
um but all but later on i started to
think about it i thought
no i have the right to feel bad because
what's happening to me is bad
there's nothing wrong with me i i have a
right to feel bad about this
so that kind of led me to studying
depression so
and as i was looking at the labeling of
depression i stumbled upon
this new at the time area of psychology
called positive psychology
where they supposedly were saying oh we
shouldn't focus on deficits let's teach
people how to be happy
and i was like well i thought that once
you solve problems people could do that
on their own
but now we even need professionals to do
that
like it's like it it seemed to me to be
expanding the purview
of psychology even not just to those who
are ill but everybody everybody needs to
be taught how to be happy and i found
that
a bit troubling and i worried that it
would
increase that kind of excessive
self-attention that i had experienced
when i was younger
i think so i'm going on i'm rambling but
just to say one more thing my
undergraduate degree was in anthropology
and sociology
and i always think to really understand
something you need to
feel what it's like to believe it you
know like the kind of um
emic ethnographic perspective the um the
insider perspective
and i feel like i i could understand it
because i had felt it myself i felt what
it was like to live within that paradigm
and to believe it
before it came out of it and started to
question it and i think some of the best
theorists are like that you know they
the best critiques of the side
disciplines were psychiatrists
themselves or
are psychiatrists or psychologists
themselves because they are in it they
know it
and then they they start to think
critically about it and they know it so
well
better than i do anyway so that's how i
came to this whole study
no i personally think that's very
inspiring and i happen to know that a
lot of people in our generation
uh have very very similar trajectories
you know just kind of speak for myself
um i can empathize with a lot of what
you're talking about you know i was 16
years old
i like post punk you know i listened to
you know nirvana and joy division and
radiohead and
all these different bands and of course
i would go around to my parents i was
like nobody understands me you know
uh yeah i was obsessed with kierkegaard
for a little while and you know he
famously said you know my melancholy is
my most faithful mistress
uh i love her very much in return right
um and i remember
my parents would respond precisely by
giving me some of those self-help books
um the one that i got was
the seven habits of highly effective
teens i can't remember i got that i
think it was like 17 16 because they're
like
oh this will help solve your problems uh
but there's this real sense you know
even on my part yeah that this was
something to be dealt with
pathologically rather than socially
and it was only later that i came to
some of the social psychological
literature of the sort that you're
talking about
uh that actually suggested that there's
very much a social political dimension
to a lot of these things
i think eric fromm was the first person
i read in that regard although there
were a lot of others
um but i wanted to read a quote from
your book that i think summarizes what
you said
um very succinctly and then maybe ask
you to elaborate on some of the scenes
so this is at the opening of chapter 2
where you say happiness claims are bound
up with historical and cultural
discourses that condition their range of
meaning
uh while it has been customary to trace
the history of happiness to ancient
greece or to some
universal or eternal human quest i
contend that the concurrent interest has
far more recent origins
there are many reasons why happiness
became a plausible and appealing
description of the problems facing
society
and i think that there's a lot to that
i'm just wondering if you can tell us a
little bit about why contemporaneously
uh this has become such a fixation in
our society you know however you want to
describe it late capitalist society
neoliberal society
uh my favorite you know neoligism is you
know
post-modern neoliberal society but
however you want to characterize it
yeah i mean there's a temptation to do
like a vulgar materialist analysis and
people
do that you know so you take the
phenomenon ready made
oh we're talking a lot about happiness
must be because we're so unhappy
and the political economy or the economy
ready made and then you just jam those
two things together we're so unhappy
because capitalism makes us unhappy
and it's a nice story but that's not
what happened um and
this is why you have to be very very
careful um all history has to be studied
afresh
i don't know if that's a line from hegel
via marx but it's a good one
um basically i i
i didn't sort of when i i saw these
headlines in the newspaper all the time
right like
uh unhappiness is britain's worst social
problem for example was a big one
um why are we so unhappy and everyone
starts talking about happiness circa
you know 2007 2008 and and instead of
saying well like oh well
how many people are unhappy how unhappy
are they um why are we so unhappy
i asked who says we're unhappy
when did it become powerful to frame
claims about social issues in the
language of happiness and unhappiness
what are they claiming who are these
people where
you know ideas don't just sort of emerge
from the ether so like suddenly there's
like this critical mass of unhappiness
and it just
explodes in people's minds oh we're
unhappy what actually happened was
beginning in 1948 um some social
scientists began to do happiness surveys
and um they were you know they typically
ask people how happy they are
on a scale of one to ten or from not
very happy to very happy there's a few
different ways that they do it
um but the real thing that happened so
they've been doing these surveys for a
long time
but the big splash was when
people began very specific people
happiness economists positive
psychologists and so on
began to take these happiness surveys
and combine them
with data with economic data and that
was the big claim
that that really burst forth onto the
scene into the public sphere of claims
making these sort of this became the
banner of a concerted campaign to make
happiness
into a public issue into a policy issue
into something that is taught in schools
it was it was a concerted agenda that
formed around these claims
um and the the the claim was in spite
of enormous economic growth in spite of
huge increases in wealth
in spite of increases in incomes
whatever they would use a bunch of
different monetary indicators
we are no happier than we were when
happiness surveys started
so if you take if you look at the trend
line for these happiness surveys
it doesn't change very much people on a
scale of one to ten people rate
themselves
as about a seven and different countries
will rate themselves differently as well
but it doesn't change much
um and now that on its own doesn't say a
whole lot but you plot that
on a graph with gdp and you've got a
really interesting story to tell
in spite of huge increases in wealth we
are no happier
so what's all this money for and that
became this really compelling claim
it had this a campaign is really likely
to make an impact to affect policy to
become institutionalized
if it appeals to the left and right at
the same time for various reasons
so it had a left wing kind of ring to it
yeah man money doesn't make you happy
like capitalism is all about consumers
and especially at this time you know
there was nothing in the beatles song
you know
uh money can't buy me love you know what
i mean
has this like counter cultural appeal to
it but also it fits really well with
conservative ideas because um it's this
like you know the protestant ethic you
know
the good capitalist doesn't consume he
plows everything back into production
um capitalists don't want their workers
to consume a whole bunch no
because they're going to ask for higher
wages so you want your
workers to be aesthetic you want
somebody else's workers preferably in
another country to be profligate
and so it worked there too right you can
well imagine because you don't go on a
picket line like pay me less give me
well-being wednesdays
i want mindfulness training you're like
f that noise i want
uh i want higher wages and there's
actually this wonderful
um story that i came across when i was
doing my research so i gathered all
these claims together to try to make
sense of what these people
were claiming and it's very it was a it
was an agenda put forward by positive
psychologists to make like happy
institutions um happy education happy
architecture like they had nodes
and they actually specifically met in
mexico yearly
i think it was yearly um to like try to
bring people from around the world to
spread this
these claims these ideas were like it
was a very conservative campaign to make
it a big deal
so there was this idea that money
doesn't make you happy right um
and so this became like the the big
claim and that's why it became so
powerful
it you know it appeals to both the left
and the right for various reasons
um and so but it was also like a
political project on the part of these
of this group of people
so it spoke to this kind of
counter-cultural heir
and you know it sounded it sounded
convincing it sounded
radical and this was a time when this is
this uh initially
sort of burst forth onto the scene in
like 1998
and then someone really took hold of it
and made it into a concerted project in
2003
um richard layard in the uk and then
more
more and more books get written about it
and that kind of thing um
and the um the idea
is that you know a huge range of social
problems can be solved
by reorienting to the true meaning of
happiness
um and you know it's it's radical it's
revolutionary but it also has a
historical
element to it right since tiny memorial
people have
once pursued happiness it's in the
declaration of independence even though
that's not what they meant
um it so it has this it had this like
radical ring to it at a time when big
ideas were on the wane
you know where there is no alternative
to capitalism has become like a
popular prejudice um and so it seemed to
provide an alternative and it spoke to
the left and right equally
so these are part of the reasons
obviously in the whole book i explain
all these different reasons
um but that's part of the reason why i
became so powerful and it wasn't because
suddenly because of capitalism in some
unmediated way we all just became very
unhappy in fact even according to the
claims makers themselves we are just as
happy as we were in 1948
which is interesting because you think
like the whole like cultural pessimism
that we have we think we're all
why are we so miserable but actually we
rate ourselves just as happy as we ever
uh we ever have and that's there's a lot
of debate about why that is it might be
like cultural feeling rules you know
like when
you say how are you saying fine thanks
it's like oh geez people keep saying
they're fine
or we like you know as long as you're
not starving you know you rate yourself
about a six
oh yeah i i want to just say one thing
and then i'll let uh victor ask this
question just but uh
what um your criticism reminded me a
little bit and maybe you'll push back
against this comparison or maybe you'll
embrace it
uh but it was the comment that uh
slavajis made uh around very similar
points
uh because one of the things that he
points out is you have a movie like the
pursuit of happiness that presents
one image of what the good life is about
uh it's a very conservative image you
know
there's will smith like you said uh he
works hard he's thrifty he looks after
his son
eventually becomes a big shot in the
world of finance and he becomes quote
unquote happy per se right and that's
a very conservative way of
conceptualizing happiness uh you
juxtaposed that with the more kind of
new age conception of happiness uh
then i think in some ways you're
criticized that you're critical of um or
you might want just call it the new left
conception
which is you know actually it's
capitalism that makes us unhappy
um because you know we're driven to be
hyper competitive we're not able to
actually spend time with our kids like
they're like presented in the movie uh
you know we can't actually form
meaningful social relations
um you point out that there's a kind of
romantic critique um
that has deep roots there uh and so what
we need to do is not necessarily get rid
of capitalism per se
but moderate it right spend more time
with their kids reconnect with spiritual
traditions
uh and jiu-jitsu is also very critical
of these kinds of
injunctions right saying that in many
ways this just reifies different forms
of ideology so
i really embraced uh the kind of
commentary you're making in that respect
because i think he's
absolutely right about that in the sense
that neither of these are past
that we should be pursuing on the left
um now the conservative path or this
kind of new left approach
but anyway go ahead victor so i think
you know
we i did grow up around the same time as
you and i remember you know the
self-esteem
uh self-esteem being an aspect in you
know when i was in primary and grade
school
and um i you know in the book you focus
on the signifier of happiness and
that you know like after you wrote that
book i think there's maybe been a bit of
a shift and there's like an oscillation
in like the dominant signifier when it
comes to like our happiness and i
sometimes
and i feel like and actually it inspired
us to do an episode a few months ago
about happiness because i actually may
have made this observation
before i was familiar with your work
that it seems like now what's in vogue
is like mental health
is like the the new signifier and i i
was curious and it came up and i know it
came up in one of your chapters but i
was wondering if
what do you how do you see the
relationship between happiness as a
social problem
and the semiotics of happiness and then
like now what we might see is the
semiotics of like
mental health and i feel like there's
more in pop culture
and there's more of a of like a kind of
push to talk about
our mental health issues it's to make it
make everybody comfortable to talk about
uh how sad they are although it's always
framed uh from the angle of mental
health
yeah so you you should talk about as
much as possible so long as you
recognize it's always a medical issue
um and how dare you think it's anything
else um
but yeah so in terms of the shift from
different signifiers
um i yeah i definitely grew up in the
self-esteem movement myself when i was
10 years old i gave a speech
you know dude you're from canada sp our
speech competition's like a normal thing
because i talk about speech competitions
everyone's like what do you want about
oh yeah we did like i think three of
them uh when i was in grade six
yeah yeah yeah i used to be really good
at that
and i and i would always i'd always
choose something i knew the adults
would really like so i'd pick like jesus
because i went to catholic school
right i'd be like i'm very passionate
about this
you know i knew exactly how to pull the
strings and one year i did self-esteem
not because i thought that self-esteem
was like so important i had no
you know a vague sense of what it meant
i could spout
everything you wanted to know about it
but i had no feel for it but because i
knew when i talked about it the adults
all got very excited
oh yes this is very important so i gave
this whole speech where i like
ripped off jack canfield and anyways um
and i still remember it to this day
but um yeah it's like self-esteem was
like the really big
deal right and we're gonna teach
self-esteem in schools and it's gonna
um they said it was going to be a social
vaccine it was going to inoculate
children from future problems
and now let me tell you it did not
inoculate me from future problems or
like
all the troubles that young girls
experience you know
body image and all that sort of thing
because they're much bigger
issues going on than like looking at
yourself in the mirror and saying you're
worth it
um but it's it's interesting because the
story that self-esteem
told was um is very similar to the story
that's told by happiness and in fact
i've got the book right here this
fantastic book i think it's out of print
now the myth of self-esteem
by john p hewitt and the subtitle is
finding happiness and solving problems
in america
and this book was published in 1998 and
what's interesting is that there was
this slippage even then
between self-esteem and happiness and i
started to notice that these signifiers
they
they tend to do that so self-esteem
gradually slipped into the language of
happiness
happiness gradually slipped into the
language of well-being well-being
slipped into mental health
and i i started to identify as i kind of
kept taking these samples from public
discourses
and social media and that kind of thing
i noticed that
um they go through these these cycles
they're not quite cycles but
of um adoption expansion sorry discovery
adoption expansion and exhaustion
so this new new signifier is discovered
and it's um you know put forward with a
huge amount of fanfare
you know it's going to be a social
vaccine it's going to solve all these
problems
and it's always the same story that's
told
first you must promote x self-esteem
happiness well-being mental health
whatever
before we can ever even think about
solving why
right so y is like some intractable
issue and with self-esteem it was like
you know it was everywhere in the
feminist movement for example
how can we ever deal with patriarchy if
we do not have the self-efficacy as
women to stand up against men right so
this nice story you you come in and you
posit your new discourse
in between some intractable problem no
no no before we ever surmount that
we have to have a seminar on self-esteem
we have to make sure that our
institutions teach self-esteem
how can we ever overcome x or y
if we don't promote x it's a very very
common formulation you see it all the
time when i was doing my coding it was
always first promote x first promote x
you just saw
all the time um and then it's so it that
is a very powerful story it's very
simple story it's a magic bullet
right it's a it's a social vaccine but
it's a magic bullet it's going to solve
all kinds of problems
and people adopt it everything becomes a
nail right when you when you've got a
hammer everything becomes a nail
and then they start to as it gets
adopted and all these institutions they
start to expand it
you know because they you adopt it and
you know self-esteem gets adopted and
god knows where um like businesses every
kind of business expands it and
education and well what if we could do
it like this and we could solve this
problem and then it just it starts to
lose all meaning
it's well self-esteem also means this
and i was just in uh
so what happens when you do this kind of
research is people will mistake you for
a happiness expert
so every now and then i get invited onto
these panels and then i
i just disappoint everyone and horrify
them and
get this truck kind of shut me up cut
off my mic i was just sitting in this on
this panel these like innovators oh i
shouldn't say this
they're very nice people i'm sure
they're lovely um but they were like um
you know if only we could promote
happiness but what does happiness mean
happiness means psychological safety
right and i was like ooh this is a new
one i haven't heard this one before
because her shtick was psychological
safety right
and she's trying to link it to the
concern with happiness if you care about
happiness you're going to care about my
thing too
right so they start to expand it and
then happiness comes to
be expanded and expanded so it means
everything and if it means everything it
means nothing
and then people get exhausted by it oh
happiness enough already shut up
in fact there was actually a headline in
newsweek happiness enough already
like you get it's not novel anymore
and obviously it can never make good on
its promises but that criticism is made
right from the very beginning
but why it exhausts is because it gets
expanded everywhere its novelty is lost
and then we're hungry for the new thing
but each round creates a space in
institutions
right so you've got these self-esteem
experts you've got all these people
who've written these books or
involved in the training programs or in
this in these new services that are
created
and they're hungry for the next thing
and so then the next thing comes and
they're there they're
ready to adopt it and each in each cycle
it just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger
so self-esteem made very similar claims
to the happiness movement it's gonna be
a social vaccine
probably one of the best examples of
this is martin seligman
um he wrote a book called the optimistic
child where he was talking about
um you know self-esteem is a social
vaccine it's going to you know
stop children from having if you give
them self-esteem when they're young
they're going to not have problems when
they're older
then he writes a book in the early 2000s
about happiness it's all self-esteem
means everything it's solved
solves everything so it ultimately
solves nothing what we should really be
talking about is happiness
which is going to inoculate children
from future problems
it's the same kind of story um and then
the you know as happiness starts to
expand it has some limits i talk about
this in the book in the later chapters
it has some limits to how far you can
expand it and people start going
uh why i'm sorry it's psychological
safety i'm i
i thought it was me in a field full of
daisies i thought it was a smile for my
child
you know and so it it expands so far
that it bursts and so people will use
different vocabularies and you see over
time people start to say happiness and
well-being
happiness and well-being happiness and
well-being and then it becomes
well-being and mental health
because well-being was a more expansive
category it
allowed people to bring in all sorts of
different things because you couldn't
really say like
a healthy diet makes you happy then
like pizza on a friday night with my
husband and beer make me happy
you know like um and like just the kind
of connection that people have to their
everyday
speaking but you could talk about
well-being right and then you can tell
people what to eat
um and so it was more open to all of
these different things and then mental
health which is what i'm looking at in
the last chapter of my new book now
um which has been on the back of my neck
for like
years and years i'm not finished it i'm
supposed to finish it now
but i'm still working on this last
chapter because mental health is so
difficult to understand and piece
together i think
that it came from this expansion but
it's not the same story
and that's what i find interesting
because self-esteem was like a magic
bullet happiness was a magic bullet
when you start to get into well-being
and mindfulness there's a sense of
there was always this sense of cultural
pessimism like oh we can't solve these
problems
like at the end of the day let's just
try to make ourselves happy but within
the mental health discourse it's very
very pessimistic
um it's not even about solving problems
it's about living within the problems
and you know if you and i part of the
research that i was doing was i was
looking at
um student newspapers i was looking at
student newspapers from the 1920s and
1930s and it was
it amazed me how the young people there
they really thought that they were going
to
radically change the world in a fun in a
fundamental way and they knew what they
they knew how they were going to do it
and they had like debates between
communists and christian conservatives
and they were like no communism's way to
go or
christian conservatives and this way to
go and they really thought we're on the
precipice here
and of course it's the 1930s right it
was like the last
the last stand for these big ideas and
then in the 1940s you have this
it's so amazing right after the second
world war there's a very palpable sense
of exhaustion
all of that debate is gone you know
daniel bell said in like 1950 you know
this is the end of ideology we've
reached the end of ideology this is it
and you think like wow in 1950 geez
that's premature but that was
it was actually that was the feeling at
the time um and so these
these young people were like all of a
sudden you see 1948 people start
1950 to start talking about like the
doors of perception and let's like go do
psychedelic drugs that kind of thing
and it it really becomes sort of
internalized and you can see that now
toward the present it's this kind of
this sense that our sphere of influence
is very small and you can see that it
has gradually receded and got smaller
and smaller and smaller
to the point where even what's in your
own damn head you no longer have control
over
and that is supposed to be like a
progressive idea like
1930s it was like we're going to control
the economy we're going to like
radically control the
we're going to take the reigns of the
future and the world and everything
and now it's like oh aren't we all bit
ill
aren't we all like you know we just have
to sit back and observe
our thoughts because they're so out of
control and let's just live within the
maelstrom
learn how to have a sense of harmony
within the maelstrom that's like
actually a quote from john kabat-zinn
this mindfulness guru
it so it's from like magic bullets to
living within the maelstrom
so it's not just a cycle it's not just a
repetition i think in each time
you kind of think about it like a
sublation in hegelian terms like this
idea of like
each one kind of negates what came
before it but also brings it to a higher
level
it's like mental health kind of subsumes
and
criticizes everything that came before
but then takes that the problem
the problem of the self the problemation
of the self in relation to society
to like the ultimate conclusion where
we're it's really amazing just how
disorganized people
are um are are portrayed as being like
but in mindfulness discourse it's like
you have these
ceos like it's so wonderful that we're
all learning about mind control
and no really that's really hard by that
i'm really glad you said that because uh
you know that was kind of the sense i
got about
um mental health and like kind of
there's much more of a negativity
associated with it and like
i feel it palpably because one of the
topics in the episode that we did about
happiness was
you know it's weird because i've just
noticed that like i will admit i'm i
feel like i'm
maybe uncommonly contented person
naturally and i sometimes feel like um
it would be it's a little bit
um unfashionable to admit that because i
feel like the dominant culture is so
much talking about like
the mental health issues you have and
the mental disturbances that you have
that it's
it seems very out of vogue to talk about
happiness it's almost cringe to talk
about to use that older word now
everyone's mental health everything has
much more of a negative spin on it but i
did want to ask like how you link sort
of these views you have in
analyzing uh the semiotics of happiness
and the shifts in the way there's
um you know these narratives have an
effect on our lives and how does that
connect to
um your broadly i think marxist
perspective
and i know that you said uh in the
beginning of your book and i watched a
couple of your interviews um
but i think in the introduction of your
book you said something about um how
you know the construction of these
different um discourses
um right can have a limiting effect on
human possibilities
um as and it makes us think that these
things like at least the narratives
um and the the symbiotics whether it's
about mental health or happiness
gives people a sense that these things
are like sort of eternal or stable
um and i guess the reason i brought up
that quote and the way
maybe i would link it to marxism is
because you know i sometimes think that
right now neoliberal the neoliberal
ideology or kind of like the liberal
ideology is kind of
interestingly um about telling us that
anything is possible right like like
capitalism it's like be whoever you want
to be be whatever identity you want to
be and it's almost like this push on us
to
to find your true self and capitalism is
like the right marketplace to do that
so i guess um and i think people a lot
of people argue that that pressure
of the of choice i think jijek has
talked about like kind of the
the nauseating effect that all these
choices were confronted with have on us
um and i wonder if there's a tension or
a link between like
the sorts of possibilities that you
don't want to be limited from a marxist
perspective
versus this sort of story that
capitalism neoliberalism tells us
about like you know that there that
anything is possible that we can be
we can find whatever true self we choose
to have right from a liberal perspective
so they're probably different but i
don't know i don't know if uh
if you get the drift of the the sort of
connect broad connection i'm trying to
make
i actually just want to follow that up
because um one of the things that i
wanted to say is that
i've often felt that one of the worst
things to emerge from the kind of trends
that you're talking about
uh is the kind of injunction to manage
your mental health uh
as a real imperative and i think a lot
of this is associated also with the
emergence of things like
uh millennial capitalism uh and the kind
of attitudes that are associated with
that
because the way that i've understood it
is that or experienced it is that
people are far more willing to let you
talk about your mental health than they
might have been in previous generations
and i do see that as a positive
development
uh but it almost always comes with an
imperative which is that you are
supposed to
manage yourself in order to replicate
the kind of pathologies that we think
are
appropriate at this given time and not
only are you supposed to do that
but it's also economically necessary for
you to do so
which is why your employer can now start
taking interest in your mental health
uh and do things kind of like what
you're talking about with the boss right
who's like
i'm gonna be here i'm working with you
know you're not just gonna go work a
nine to five any longer because it's
important for me to help manage
your psychology in a certain sense
because we want our workers to be upbeat
and productive
right uh and in some ways my response to
that is almost
a kind of gen x attitude of becoming
very cynical
uh towards a lot of this happiness
discourse uh and to suggest that it's
just a way of
evading uh taking responsibility for the
construction of a different kind of
social destiny uh
that might actually resolve some of the
material problems that we're facing
right now
but anyway i just wonder if you can
speak to that yeah absolutely um
so i mean obviously with the
rise of like emotionality at work
i mean i feel that this is like an
ultimate form of control
because if you think about how
like obviously if you want to take a
fucodian perspective a lot of power if
you want to look at like a microcosm of
power in society you can look at a
prison
and how is power exercised in a prison
do they beat people into submission
yeah i mean at the end of the day they
might do that but the more progressive
power is by you you control people
by having them control themselves right
you are
you know you emote and you go to these
therapy sessions and that sort of thing
and it's at least but here's the thing
it's actually
not that progressive because in the past
at least you know when you
get beat by somebody your brain is still
yours your mind is still yours you know
if somebody beats you into submission
you can still have
you know uh your your your mind that
says this is wrong this is unjust
whatever
you can have that part of you that's
that nobody can like
hit with a baton but when you are
invited to like emote and to
display all your deepest feelings about
something
you know the and then you're invited to
adopt this script or this narrative that
brings them back in line with the
institution
the control is total you know i would
much rather have
that freedom that tiny little freedom to
go to work do my thing and say a subtle
[ __ ] you
under my breath and that's mine you know
but now i have to go in and not
like i'll i shouldn't kind of name
somebody but
someone i know sent me this horrifying
picture of like these stickers that were
handed out
at her work with all these emotions on
them and you were supposed to change
your sticker throughout the day to
advertise how you're feeling
angry that's like the worst nightmare
horrifying absolutely horrifying um and
the everybody all the workers
were like weirded out by this and
they're like um the you know the
aspirational ones were like
after that you know i'm gonna be in
management they're like oh this is so
great
and management thought it was wonderful
they were oh they were
breaking down barriers to you know the
stiff upper lip and all these sorts of
things
um and everyone else was like really
weirded out in this way with it that
they couldn't quite completely explain
because the the at least if you
you know you go in you do your thing and
the capitalist doesn't have any
access to your brain right now
not only do you have to be exploited you
have to enjoy it
um and again one of these panels that i
was on i was sitting there with my mouth
hanging open because i couldn't believe
that nobody found this weird um they
were like
oh yeah what we can do now is with
mobile phones we can actually track
people's emotions
and we can see based on their eye
movements
and we can see how they're feeling
at any point in the day and i was like
what
that's horrible but how is it justified
it's justified on the basis of breaking
down barriers let's all talk about our
emotions
um and uh let's oh and another one that
here's one that they stick with a stick
that they beat people with is uh suicide
right so they threaten people if we
don't do this we're gonna you know
people are gonna commit suicide
and this is you know have you ever read
the book the circle
um in that novel that was how like the
the tracking devices right so it's like
the the thing or like microchipping
people the the quintessential
tinfoil hat thing the state wants to
microchip you
well how did they introduce microchips
by saying
um it's gonna stop uh little girls from
being abducted and we'll be able to find
people you know so it's always through
this kind of moral crusade
that um gradually our kinds of our kinds
of freedoms are lost and the freedom
to be miserable is something that is
actually really
important and to have that misery to be
able to articulate that misery with
other people
is something that's gone now um because
you know you think about the word stress
oh i'm stressed out when did this become
become powerful in common parliament in
the 1960s
and was it because suddenly the world
became much more stressful in the 1960s
no absolutely not i mean think about
what it was like during the industrial
revolution people's limbs getting ripped
off on a regular basis like children
falling into machines
people working 18-hour days like karl
marx and capital as all these vignettes
of like people forced to work around the
clock before they'd like literally drop
dead
you think like why didn't they use the
word stress because there was another
narrative that existed at that time
where you could
gather together and and demand
rights through collective social
movements the trade union movement was
on the wane
um and you can actually see that the
this huge rise in disability as
the um as the uh union movement starts
to disappear and so we have this kind of
individualized narrative
and this language of emotion the
language of mental health speaks to this
kind of individualized narrative
your problems are you you are feeling
bad today
you have this issue you can um
carry out these practices like they even
have like biohacking now where it's like
companies are like oh you can play with
the lights and um
get the ambience exactly right to make
to make people not pissed off
so but they'll also like invite you to
do it to yourself
like you biohack yourself and that so
that you don't feel like you're a
hamster in a flipping treadmill you know
um and so i think that this is it that's
some really good stuff i have to say
like that's yeah and they will actually
say mind control because they say that
we can't control our own minds
so they're going to teach you how to do
it and people are like okay
and this you know you ask me how do i i
connect this to marxism
because we do that is the most
fundamental thing about being a human
being
by working on the world you work on
yourself what is human nature
we create our own nature that is the
most
quintessential aspect of marxism because
it allows us to
recreate a new world and recreate whole
new ways of being
it's not our mind is not like the world
around us is not just a product
projection of human nature
it changes and as we do things
differently we change our own nature we
are fundamentally different today
than we were a thousand years ago people
wouldn't have an existential crisis
in the year 800 oh i'm 16 years old who
am i what am i going to be in the world
no you knew that because you saw what
your mother did you saw what your father
did you're just going to live that life
but because we now have all these
different choices we do have an
existential crisis
but that is because we have that ability
as human beings to choose who we are
now we're in a context in which we don't
have a robust kind of
subjectivity to deal with those kinds of
choices right so if you're going to
choose who you are everything
up to you is a choice you also have to
stand behind that and say i have chosen
to be this way this is the path that i
have taken
and therefore when it all goes to [ __ ]
it's kind of my fault or when it all
goes to [ __ ] it's probably some deeper
kind of structural thing and you just
got spat at the bottom that's kind of
hard
a hard thing to to understand but i
think the reason why this all bothers me
is because human subjectivity is
variable
and what happens with these kinds of
discourses is a very
static very weak very vulnerable
subjectivity is posited as progressive
but we need a powerful subjectivity
we need a changing subjectivity
if we are to fundamentally change the
world if we are to
take the reigns of history and like us
mark says we like in the past we you
know everything's sort of like chaos
and now it is in the anarchy of
production and so on but we will make
history in the full light of reason
and where and capitalism is bringing us
you know the veil is lifted and we're
getting closer and closer to the truth
of
the human hands on history we have to
realize that
it is us that have done everything we
have created religions we have created
these institutions
we can recreate them we can make them
different and all of these discourses
invite us to think no no no
we're all just a bit messed up aren't we
it's so hard to control our minds and
you know the government really needs you
it needs to lock the cookie box or
whatever they say
with nudge discourses that kind of thing
we're just your better self
because you're weak and isn't it so
progressive to accept that
well that leads right into it that's
really very inspiring about
um you know so if we're if we're going
to be critical of you know
these kind of structural explanations
where we want to like blame capital or
culture for
our feelings and then we also you know
want to be critical of medicalizing kind
of like internal chemical balances
or other kind of like personal
responsibility narratives for how we're
feeling
um you know i guess i would i'd be
curious about how you respond to people
who would say well maybe that leads to
like kind of a mental health quietism
where it's like we can't talk about
anything and then i guess that leads to
the natural question which is
what do you think is the right way to
talk about mental disturbances and i
know that you're inspired by ian
hacking's like you know the looping
effect right and that that does lead to
like a very kind of
a difficult puzzle where you're like you
know if we start to over label something
it like has an effect and it's almost
like we're making it real so given that
i guess
how do you see the way forward to talk
about something that clearly all of us
have some sort of intuitive uh
experience with what i don't know mental
disturbance or whatever we want to call
it
unhappiness or whatever yeah i also want
to follow up and say that i think
a lot of what you're talking about
really came to the fore uh in 2020
because i remember
one of the objections that republicans
made uh to actually giving people
fifteen hundred dollars a month
uh in order to stay at home was oh
without people working
uh suicide rates are going to increase
and drug rates are going to increase
we don't want that because people need
the kind of meaning they get from going
to work
every single day and there was really
this kind of perverse quality to it of
course because
they knew that if more people go to work
more people are going to die but that
was still preferable to
undertaking what's really a very minor
change uh to the economic status quo
just giving people a month
uh i'd like money a month to stay home
but even that was
a bridge too far for the people who are
caught up
in these kinds of justificatory logics
well with that last
bit um it's a bit difficult because i
think when you're in the united states
it's easy to get drawn into this idea
that the discourse of capitalism or the
ideology of capitalism that we need to
um fight against is the kind of obvious
one like the
coca-cola be happy the thing is like
nobody is like oh i'm gonna buy this
coke and it's gonna make me so happy
nobody flipping thinks that like you
know so you're it's it's kind of like
straw man to begin with but also
you still have this kind of um you still
have capitalists
in the us who are like these kind of
like old fashioned
um productivists um which you know
i think they're really really on the
wane um
because there's this kind of like fight
between within the capitalist class you
have like the people who are like
quite progressive in the sense of like
economically progressive and so they
think like oh we're gonna produce tons
and tons of stuff and that's gonna
like rising tide will lift all boats
that kind of thing but the real the
people who are really in the know the
people who are
really progressive in like the liberal
sense they are
like you i when i again when i said on
these panels with rich people like
people with money
i have to actually tell them the purpose
of business is profit
and they get very uncomfortable with
that no no
it's not it is about all of these
different things we have goals and i
said yeah okay you can have all that
stuff
but if you don't make a profit you're
gonna go out of business okay well maybe
that's true but it's
profit and all of this stuff yes okay
but if you don't make a profit
screw all that other stuff because
you're gonna go out of business
right and so there's this enormous push
to like deny that the
purpose of capitalism is to make more
money it is
it is and that's the good thing about it
there's me being a heretic that is the
good thing about capitalism
because it creates a basis of abundance
that the world that could feed the world
many times over that if we could figure
out how to harness
for human beings is the basis of a new
and much better society
and this is why if you read the grin
recent notebook 7 it's wonderful i
recommend everybody read it because marx
is absolutely giddy
about this and he says the the basis of
wealth on the on
um sorry the creation of wealth on the
basis of the exploitation of human labor
appears as a miserable foundation um
uh in light of this new one that's being
created by industry itself
why in like capitalism is creating it is
abolishing
exploitation to create a much better
world
so these progres like progressive
economically progressive capitalists
they have no idea that they are creating
the basis of communism
which is why people think that i'm a
confusing figure because
i love a capitalist who will be honest
about profit
the ones that freak me out are the ones
who will deny that
because capitalism is contradictory it's
not just like oh
growing growing yay everybody's rich if
that was what capitalism did what would
be the problem
capitalism is also tense towards
stagnation the thing that creates wealth
is also the thing
that creates stagnation um so um
you know in the communist manifesto marx
talks about it like the capitalist is
like the
um the wizard or the sorcerer who's
unable to control the powers he's
conjured up from the netherworlds
at the netherworld and this thing that
was once a progressive force for
humanity begins to hold us back
that it becomes its the thing that
creates wealth starts to hold back the
creation of wealth
and so there are people who see this
however stupidly they understand that
this is what's happening
so economic growth uh is slowing down
relatively slowing down it's very hard
to find profitable avenues for
investment
and if you are not honest if you will
if you're like a horrible person and you
want to hold not a horrible person but
like you
you know horrible ideologically you want
to hold on to this system
just for the sake of holding on to this
system which is unforgivable
then you will say well who needs
economic growth anyway
too much consumption makes us discontent
who needs
profits maybe we can shift to something
else within all of this you know they'll
try to create this imaginary world where
this isn't destructive
destructive they'll try to harmonize
things or what marks
called they try to reconcile
irreconcilables
so like mill like um the falling rate of
profit was something that was
widely recognized in by early political
economist it wasn't does the
rate of profit fall it was why does it
fall and mills tried to harmonize this
he said
well maybe it's just a steady state to
which capitalism is naturally advancing
and mark says this is ridiculous this
this steady state to which we are
advancing
is the twilight of the gods the end of
the world basically for capitalism
because why would you invest if there's
no return on investment
you know and and that's crisis for the
rest of us
you know when the economy fails to grow
it is efficient right
you are the first to go you are the
first to lose your job that
you know you are embedded in that um and
so i think it's important to recognize
you know you have this idea of like oh
the capitalist they want to make money
it's a lot more complicated than that
and there are plenty of capitalists who
are happy to
get bailouts to have us live in misery
to admiserate us
as much as possible and to claim that
they're being progressive by doing it oh
you know
too much consumption makes you unhappy
anyway
okay well i did i mean i did i did want
to try to because because i think maybe
you got a little bit caught up in matt's
part of the question there because i
still was hoping to get an answer on the
question of you know
whether or not being critical of the
discourses of mental health leads to
kind of like mental health quietism and
like i guess how would you
like what is the correct way or what do
you think is the right way to talk about
um
mental health or mental disturbances
without you know falling victim to the
effects that you're being critical of
that we can connect like hacking's
looping effect
which that is is open to question and
then there's a big question of how much
of it
is our medicalization of distress so
it's not that we should stop talking
about
distress but i think we should think
twice about whether or not these things
are medical issues
have we basically medicalized a huge
range of human reactions to conditions
and on top of that it's not like this is
what scares me about the idea of like
emotion being a new kind of truth
it is so variable like you can convince
people to feel all sorts of different
ways
it's so malleable right like with money
or something like that you can like
measure it right but with
emotion it's not like like i can make
you feel better about a shitty wage
like that's scary right um so i think we
have to be careful about
you know one medicalizing emotion and
two we have to recognize that
emotion is malleable it's not like oh
this thing happens we feel this way
cause and effect like we're lab rats or
something like that
in between event and subjectivity is a
whole world of interpretation of
culture of history and so on that
determines or influences how you react
to a particular situation
and also like interpersonal things um
and so it's it's not like
oh bad thing happens everybody's gonna
feel this exact way it's
it's not like that so it's not like oh
like capitalism is here and where
it makes us feel bad and i want you to
talk about that it's like well we have
to
interrogate why we are being invited to
conceive of the problems of capitalism
largely as
psychological issues and actually it's
not even it's a terrible critique anyway
because most people are fine
like that's amazing to me this horrible
exploitative system and yet most people
are fine
and in fact oscar wilde says this in his
famous essay soul of man under socialism
the worst part part about slavery wasn't
that it made people discontent the worst
part is that they
didn't know they were discontent and had
to be told of it by outsiders
like a horrible institution like slavery
and many when they were freed
bitterly regretted the situation
partially because they were so free
indeed they were free to starve
um but that's that's the idea is that um
um discontent is not like this sort of
um as widespread as our kind of like
pessimistic culture likes to think of it
um and emotions are pretty malleable i
invite a much deeper i wish i want us to
have a much deeper critique of
capitalism
that comes from which has been lost and
which has largely been supplanted by
these kind of emotional critiques
which is based on economics that is
based on a
critique of the internal workings of
capitalism which is why i like mark so
much because he doesn't start with human
psychology
he doesn't start with greed he doesn't
start with humans making mistakes
he starts with the very same things as
the classical political economist did
the free willing rational subject and he
points out how
even if you are acting rationally these
things will happen
the crises will happen it is the outcome
of something within the system
itself and that is why i'm such a fan of
marxism because it is
it is a truly humanist discourse you
have all these like right wingers who
claim to stay
hold the mantle for humanity like oh no
humans have the ability to have free
will
they don't really believe that because
how can they pause how do they explain
things when they go wrong
those people are idiots you know so
immediately they they lose faith
in human beings they don't really
believe in human subjectivity because
they
the only explanation when things go
wrong is human subjectivity
equilibrium economics needs some
external thing to
understand crisis marxist economics
doesn't
it comes from the proper functioning of
the system itself
and the other thing that um i wanted to
say so what do we do
i think i remember having a conversation
with edgar cabanas who's
really really good i'm a big fan of him
and he's a psychologist and i was very
surprised with this
he sort of shrugged his shoulders and he
said i just don't think about my
feelings very much
and it was kind of the same the same um
feeling that i have uh feeling the same
kind of uh
um idea that i've wound up with is i
just don't really think about my
feelings so much
um and it's not that i like suppress
things because we have this ideology now
suppression oh it must be deep down it's
going to explode right the
sort of repressive idea but it's that
because i'm focused on a project beyond
myself because i am
passionate about trying to understand
the world and in that understanding try
to figure out a way to
change it to give human beings greater
freedom to remove the obstacles to
freedom and because i believe that human
beings
once we do that they will be able to
pursue their own
happiness however that whatever that
might be
in the sense of you have the freedom to
do whatever you want to do
and i'm not going to tell you what you
should want to do i'm not going to tell
you how you should find happiness
saying when you don't have to work for a
capitalist
for like i don't know how much percent
of your existence i've done math really
quick but
a huge percentage of your existence
wasted on some other asshole's plan
what would you do with your life i think
all of our lives would be a lot
a lot different and yeah maybe we would
be miserable in different ways but
that's you that's that's your own
personal world i am interested in
increasing the freedom of human
beings um by removing the barriers to
freedom that exist now
and i and trying to recognize where we
have those pathways of freedom
that capitalism open up opens up and at
the same time tries to shut down
um so focus on a project beyond yourself
and that actually comes from psychology
from victor frankl
right this idea that you pursue
something beyond yourself not because it
makes you happy
but because it makes suffering
worthwhile and if you think that the
ultimate
goal of everything you do is to produce
a feeling inside your head
you are always going to be disappointed
you're always going to be discontented
because you cannot by their nature
feelings are ephemeral they
they slip away the moment that you have
it it's gone and
that means that you're if that's your
whole purpose in life you're always
going to be chasing something
that can it never really exists because
you can't hold on to it
and people say like oh money blah blah
blah you you can't take it with you
yeah but you can't at least you can
leave that behind
with your feelings you can't leave them
behind they're gone when you're gone
with a project beyond yourself something
beyond yourself
it's there after you're gone right you
can leave it behind you can't take it
with you but you can leave it behind
and you do it because it matters and
it's meaningful not because it'll make
you happy
actually i want to say your last comment
reminded me a lot of simone de beauvoir
she made a very similar point where she
stipulated that one of the biggest
problems with the philosophy of
subjectivity is precisely that it leads
us to think that
the only thing that matters is how it is
that we feel about something and so
life becomes a conscious like a constant
effort to try to manage our feelings in
one way shape or form
and it's only when we realize that we're
actually very much other directed
preachers
and we find our significance in the
relations that we uh have with uh with
different people you know whether our
family our friends and so on uh that we
become
truly gratified uh because of the
recognition that we get from them but of
course that's very difficult under
capitalism and under patriarchy
so that's why we need to reform those
kind of systems right yeah i think the
only time that i have any kind of misery
is when i feel that my project may not
go anywhere
and i feel that that perhaps
we will never move beyond this that this
possibility that we have
you know this world of wealth and
culture just beyond the horizon if we
could just figure out how to take hold
of it and generalize it
we're almost there it's possible and we
we can't figure out a way to get there
and i
then i feel deep deep dejection but i
feel like that's like a kind of thing
that's a dejection that's connected to
the world you know into connected to
other people
um and the sort of broader project of
humanity as opposed to me being like
oh why can't i be happy about like
my sitting on a prayer mat for 20
minutes a day why is this not fulfilling
me
kind of thing not that there's anything
wrong with that if that makes you if
that makes you tick that's fine i
my main issue with the whole meditation
thing is that it's put forward as like a
solution to social problems you know
it's the same kind of magic thing
somehow some way if we could just
promote x somehow we would do y
um but yeah well it sounds like i mean
it sounds like what you're saying is you
know those
all these things are fine it's more
about like how are you taking it up
right because i think that the key
at least if i'm understanding you
correctly right is is are you taking
that thing up as a project in your life
right and it's not this like thing that
is uh that you're doing because you
think it's gonna like solve some problem
like instrumentally or something in your
mental health is it something that
you're
so i guess presumably it would be
possible to take up yoga or these other
things as like a project
if i'm not if i'm not misunderstood like
i go to the gym and that kind of thing
i like you know i like to do that um i
don't think that that's like
the be all in the end all of my purpose
it is for my husband though and he's
like
a pretty contented guy like right there
there you go there you go
you know i mean it's it's to each it's
you know teach their own but if you do
it like i know my friend does it because
she believes it like increases
endorphins
and she's pretty like sad all the time
you know she has no purpose in her life
and she specifically goes to the gym
and this instrumental way to increase
endorphins and i feel like that's kind
of sad
but that i don't know i'm not i'm not
totally i'm not that interested in kind
of like
individuals i'm more interested in you
know these sort of broader discourses
and what they say about our social
movements and that kind of thing so when
i say project
in life i mean like you know you know
what i have in mind i'm sneaking in
marxism
i'm sneaking in communism but you know
everybody will have something different
you know yeah for sure for sure so yeah
i did want to ask you about your rt
article so like for some of our
listeners right a lot of them are
americans so they may not know that in
kamloops british columbia right there is
a discovery under
a residential school where indigenous
people indigenous children were taught
there was i think over
plus 200 plus bodies of children found i
think with some sort of like radio
um technology i'm not actually sure if
they've done the digging yet but i think
that they
they did identify like a bunch of what
seemed like children's bodies
and you wrote an article about it and
you said something in it that i thought
was a pretty spicy take
um you said something like you know um
uh yeah so i'll quote you you said as a
canadian indigenous person myself who
grew up hearing stories
uh of the horrors of residential school
i too was outraged when i first heard
about the
misguided school assignment but i've
come but i've since come to realize that
the constant invitation to expound
atrocity tales the constant expansion of
victimhood the tendency to see every
single indigenous person
as a trauma as traumatized has a darker
edge
so i wonder if you could talk about that
darker edge and also maybe
um what do you think is the right way or
or the
with your view at least to talk about
trauma and the effect that it has on us
stop [ __ ] talking about trauma sorry
okay
okay can you tell us a bit about the
response also to that article because
like victor's saying i imagine there's
got to be some people who were
jose a little peeved uh by what really
is a very innovative account of
uh you know how it is that people should
respond to these kind of social
historical
looks okay when i hear these stories and
i know them because they're in my own
family
as well um yeah it upsets me a lot and i
had to explain to my daughter i'm gonna
cry
um i had to explain my daughter what
happened you know
and she said you know you know i i tried
to explain to her and i said you know
what what what they did um and then you
know these bad things happen in the
world that kind of thing maybe i
shouldn't but i was quite upset about it
when i when i saw it on
you know when the story broke yeah it is
really upsetting it's a horrible thing
that happened
but the idea that every single
indigenous person is traumatized by this
and has mental health problems like they
literally say this
and they you know is used against us
first of all it is incorrect not
everybody went to residential schools
not everybody's um you know not
everybody's
ancestors um had that kind of tough time
you know some people actually had a a
pretty decent time
i know that's horrible but i mean like i
mean like when i say a decent time i
don't mean residential schools although
actually there are
like apparently something like 10 of
people that have positive stories about
it
now that's all like it's absolutely
horrible to say that because these were
horrible horrible institutions but my
point is
um the whole idea of like through some
kind of thing
colonization that happened at some point
in the past every single generation is
damaged
is just not true and we don't say that
about any other group
in society we say that about indigenous
people and here's the thing this is why
it bothers me
because when it comes to what's
happening right now
which is um what's called the millennium
scoop enormous numbers of children are
being taken
still they're still doing it do you know
why because we're they claim that we're
damaged
they claim that we because of
residential schools because of
colonialism
we have lost our ability to be mothers
that is exactly what they said when they
took
our kids and put them in residential
schools they said because we
couldn't be mothers the indigenous woman
could not raise the liberal citizen
they're still saying that the only thing
is it sounds great because they're
blaming themselves
they're not even blaming themselves
they're blaming past governments um so
it's like a bad old government of the
past that did all these terrible things
we're so
sorry and that is why you have problems
today
so the i wrote a paper about this it's
not it's just um
that rt article is literally my stream
of consciousness when i was very angry
when it first broke literally i thought
that the editor would edit it
because there's like half sentences in
there i wrote it in a fit of rage
um and the editor was like this is
powerful i'm going to print it as it is
and i was like no you might want to not
do that
but i wrote a whole paper that is much
more thought out where i go through all
these discourses and i explain how they
function
but basically what they do is they the
uh
explicit source of problems in
indigenous communities now
is past colonial governments but the
implicit
uh source of these problems is the
damage to parents
so because of the past the actions of
government we've damaged parents and now
they
truly in the past it wasn't true but now
it is uh now they truly are not able to
take care of their children
but this is actually a very old
understanding of social problems and
it's actually one of the the
understanding of social problems that
influence the idea of residential
schools in the first place called social
pathology
which basically says that that
people individuals are pathological
and they um if we could like kind of go
in and fix them and give them the right
kind of education
we would solve their social problems so
the source of social problems is the
pathological individual
so the organism is healthy that society
is healthy
and the individual is like a pathology
within like a sickness within the
otherwise healthy body
and so social pathology perspectives had
this idea okay well if we could just
take the indian
out of the home right and stop them from
being like a little parasite
make them nice good white people then
they'll be good cells to put back into
the healthy body that was the idea
and now now that social pathology
has slipped into pathological
civilization
which says society itself is sick and it
infects individuals
and this infection perpetuates the
sickness so still we have to go into
individuals and fix them
give them the medicine of whatever
intervention you want to give them
and and this is actually a very
widespread understanding the sort of
pathological civilization i talked about
in the first chapter of my book
this is a very widespread understanding
of social problems because it has again
that leftist kind of ring the sick
society right
um but it still is the same thing as the
old right wing social pathology
you at the end of the day you still
think individuals are sick
and if we could give them the right
medicine we would fix them so we have
all of these parenting interventions to
try to go in and teach indigenous
mothers to be better parents
which is basically just to give them the
ideology of intensive parenting which is
the ideology that governs parenting in
white society
and especially working class white
society and we go in and we and we try
to make them
uh intensive so but it gets globalized
right it's the it's this idea of like oh
intensive parenting is actually what you
used to do before colonization messed
you up and stopped you being able to
raise your kids
um and so they wrap up with what is a
modern discourse of parenting and
pathology which says that all social
problems are ultimately down to what
parents do
they wrap that up in indigenous language
like oh it's the
your ancestors and the elders that used
to teach you how to raise your children
and here's the four directions
and this direction is preconception so
make sure you eat right when you're
pregnant
[ __ ] um and they basically just wrap
up all of these
um very like individualized
interventions that they use on the
working class
to they blame the working class for like
cycles of social problems they do the
exact same thing indigenous communities
but they wrap it up in indigenous
language
and the language of colonialism so
basically what they do is they
pathologize parents in the exact same
way that they used to
and they say well we're very sorry about
this
in the past it wasn't true but now it is
and that's why we have to take your
children
there are enormous numbers of children
in carrot they're still taking them
the problems that we have on reserves
are material they're down to lack of
infrastructure
they're the same kinds of problems you
have when you're poor anywhere okay it's
not a psychological problem we're not
freaking traumatized
you can't get a job then you're gonna be
poor like you're gonna you're not gonna
you just spend your life like what do
you do
you know you wind up like just drinking
that's what winds up happening
um and these are the same kinds of
problems that you have everywhere it's
not because we're traumatized
stop with the trauma stuff this was a
this is a discourse that's been
introduced
relatively recently it is it is
very very damaging and there's another
very good book about this called
therapeutic nations by diane milian
who's
an american indigenous academic and she
goes into this in the
australian context as well where they
use these discourses to rescind
self-determination
how can you self-determine if you're so
messed up
if you're so psychologically damaged if
we all have ptsd
how can we can't even raise our children
it really is kind of obnoxious the way
uh the
this kind of social pathologization that
you're talking about uh becomes
individuated and rather than actually
dealing with the kind of material
conditions
uh that have led many of these
communities into poverty for such a long
time
uh there's just this endless effort uh
to try to
relocate it uh in the individual even if
it's
somewhat better now um because they'll
say at least while the previous
governments are partly responsible for
that right
it's really quite noxious and i think
it's a really sure that it's better
i'm not even sure that it's better
because they just deflect they
they may they draw a line they're doing
the same thing
yeah okay so we lost her uh ashley can
you hear us
i did i did want to like briefly well it
looks like maybe the internet's unstable
so maybe maybe we should just maybe we
should just end it here i think uh
if we'll we'll get her back because i
think that that was a good point to end
on anyway
yeah i mean i can hear it you can just
leave it there i mean i i ranted i
rented anyway
no it was so good i mean it was honestly
it was so interesting um
yeah like i i mean i guess i mean i had
more things i wanted to ask you but like
we're
already at time anyway and and the
internet's a little inconsistent anyway
so maybe maybe sometime in the future
we can do it again or bring you on
another time uh yeah i mean i regret i
regret
saying like uh that not everybody had a
bad experience in residential schools
that's not what i meant i meant like not
everybody had a bad experience like
like literally every single human person
indigenous person from
1492 to the present of course
we can add that in sorry that's not yeah
i but
but it actually is it is an interesting
point that like 90 to 95 percent of
people had a bad experience but five to
10
people of people had a good
oh [ __ ] ptsd is not in our dna
yeah got it well i just want to say
ashley thanks a lot for coming on i
thought that was really interesting
conversation
and hopefully we can have you back some
other time because i would definitely
like to
follow up on the kind of comments you
are making there at the end because
again i think that the dynamic that
you're talking about there
is really noxious but very interesting
um particularly when it comes to how it
is that we should interrogate
uh but the social and individual
pathologization that seems to be rampant
uh in our society right now
uh well and also just the way the left
is kind of i feel like the left has been
infected by this
this this language of trauma not just in
the indigenous context but in so many
other contexts i feel like so yeah
there's a lot of other
interesting stuff to pick up on there's
a lot of really good literature about it
i highly recommend you read diane
millions therapeutic nations
very very good takedown of it all sounds
so good it all sounds
progressive but it's being used against
us absolutely
well thanks a lot ashley and again uh
check out our book the semiotics of
happiness and
i guess i'll give you the last word so
can you tell us a little bit about the
name
and the subject of the new book uh that
you're working on right now
so the new book is called significant
emotions which looks at the
cycling of these different uh discourses
how one gives way to the next
basically as i met as i talked about
cycles of
discovery adoption expansion and
exhaustion tries to get at what is
underlying all of this which i think is
um
diminished subjectivity brought on by a
real loss of freedom
so that our avenues of freedom are
actually shutting down
and i think that's what underlies our
inability to understand human beings in
any other way except
vulnerable and infected by various
pathologies and so on
great and you can find her on twitter
too in the description
and thanks again thank you so much
[Music]
you